so I think what they're feeling is real
if you take your own life the sadness
you're feeling is deeply real but it's
not due to like a chemical imbalance and
you know you're just born that way and
that's it now you just need to take
pills cuz that's what the doctors tell
you I remember I lived with a girl at
University and she had depression and
anxiety I was trying to tell her to like
get over it and sort herself out and she
was like no it's a chemical imbalance
and I can't do anything about it that's
pathetic that's victim mentality that's
weak mentality and I just don't buy into
that you have too much time on your
hands you have too much privilege that's
why you're depressed cuz you have way
too much privilege if you literally had
to fend for your life and survive you
wouldn't have any time for depression
you'd be focused on when's your next
meal going to be